mobile ux design is tricky there are so
many things we have to consider
including the growing list of mobile
devices the ways people interact with
them and the fact that people want
consistent experiences across all device
types to create great mobile ux you need
to follow the best practices developed
over the last several years this video
presents some of the rules and
guidelines that will help even a
beginner to create top-notch mobile ux
design rule number one conduct the
end-to-end research
even if you have already created dozens
of projects for a specific business
Niche each time it should be accompanied
by in-depth marketing research
therefore before creating a layout drop
a portrait of the client and the
corresponding user flow Maps this way
you can ensure maximum intuitiveness a
great tool you can utilize in your
end-to-end research is the flow map
product which consists of a number of
useful ux tools make sure to check it
out when you have a chance
rule number two focus on the most
important you should understand that the
uniqueness of the user experience isn't
identical to its diversity
I mean that to create something
recognizable many ux designers often
accompany the user interface with
unnecessary functionality as a result
the entry level turns out higher and it
becomes more difficult for beginners to
adapt to using it intuitively just
remember minimalism is your best friend
rule number three explore the technology
stack used for your project when mobile
Concepts like amp and pwa come into play
it's important to understand that this
should also be reflected in user
interface design
for example in the first case you can
use css3 without any restrictions as for
the second you will have to think
through scenarios where push
notifications are appropriate and user
device Hardware is used rule number four
provide intuitive navigation for the
main elements of the project
don't forget that it can be difficult
for beginners to navigate even in
interfaces with extremely minimalistic
functionality that's why I recommend
leaving additional hints that encourage
the next steps towards achieving the
user's goal
otherwise your solution may be useless
for those users who don't want to spend
a lot of time reading manuals rule
number five deliver the best user
experience on the touch plane even
though Humanity has been using touch
screens to interact with mobile
applications for more than a decade some
principles for creating their interfaces
remain outdated
for example instead of making swipe
inconvenient by simulating the usual
flipping of paper Pages some designers
still create navigation buttons this is
not a very convenient solution rule
number six take care of the typography
Stylin mobile app or website is of
course great at the same time this isn't
a reason to neglect the convenience of
reading text instructions therefore
before creating a fancy design and using
non-standard fonts and text block layout
consider whether all this will increase
the entry threshold for users rule
number seven provides seamless feedback
create an interface in such a way that
responds with some kind of reaction to
any user action this will help them
understand whether they are moving along
the path to achieving the target action
conversely the lack of feedback leaves
some users confused rule number eight
eliminate the need to type regularly the
constant need for user input is unlikely
to play into your hands sometimes it's
just inconvenient sometimes very
annoying
whatever the final reactions of your
users to this remember that the fewer
input feels the better rule number nine
deliver a Multi-Device user experience
it's unlikely that the success of a
particular design solution can be
assessed by a couple of reviews from the
focus group Representatives instead
testing is much better done with the
help of special emulators which not only
repeat the typical steps of various
target audience groups but also simulate
their actions on various devices rule
number 10 don't forget about live
testing
along with testing on emulators it is
also important to test on live
representatives of the target audience
this way you can get useful feedback in
addition to Multi-Device testing of
course which you can then use to
optimize the existing template rule
number 11 create a stylish splash screen
obviously since the splash screen is the
user's first impression when using an
app or website for the first time it's
important to think of it in such a way
that it looks cool
this can be done for example the help of
colorful original animation rule number
12 minimize the number of registration
steps instead of thinking through the
steps for registering an application or
website from scratch it's much better to
use proven methods that are familiar to
every user for example you can invite
users to register through social
networks or Gmail rule number 13 don't
bombard users with permission messages
to access their personal data
although software developers are
massively practicing gdpar these days
it's important to understand where the
golden mean is that's why the next time
you design a user interface layout that
uses personal data think about it
perhaps it makes sense to request access
rights only at the beginning of using an
application or website rule number 14
think about cross-platform the fact that
the implementation of interfaces from
platform to platform shouldn't differ
much visually is obvious it's just not
clear how to implement this when you
have two separate solutions for
different platforms that is why it's
much better to try to create a universal
design for all platforms at once rule
number 15 provide a positive tone even
in negative scenarios in addition to the
positive outcome of using the created
interface it's also very important to
consider the negative ones when
something doesn't work or went wrong
in particular even if your potential
user is forced to uninstall your mobile
application he or she can receive a
reassuring notification that for example
the team of the development company
loves absolutely all of their users rule
number 16 offer users instant payments
if your application or website is part
of the e-commerce sector you can hardly
think of anything better than just
implementing the possibility of instant
payments voila your users will start
making more purchases from the first day
of updates rule number 17 remember about
security
sometimes design creates a security Gap
ranging from ill-conceived sign-in forms
to Biometrics stocks shifting all the
responsibility to the developers just
think about what you would do to hack
your app or website if you were a hacker
and try to avoid these situations when
designing your mock-ups rule number 18
prefer text indicators have you ever
noticed that some of the icons that
indicate what users need to do look
ambiguous that's why it's better to use
textual progress indicators where it's
possible rule number 19 balance the
number of push notifications to ensure
background user interaction some
developers begin to abuse pop-up
messages as a result users get annoyed
very soon naturally there is no question
of advanced user experience in such
situations rule number 20 provide top
personalization
offered a user enough options so that he
or she can adapt the interface to their
individual needs
among the basic settings are font size
and type theme sound effects Etc
as a result you will quickly see how
your target audience's loyalty here
project will increase if you found this
video useful I'd appreciate it if you
smash the like button and click on the
notification Bell
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding Tech channel for more videos like
this in the future